لقد فاجأ قرار الولايات المتحدة بعدم
إسقاطه بعض الأشخاص، هل
توافق على المنطق، فقط اترك الأمر
نعم، لأنه إذا نظرت إلى
صور البالون،
ستلاحظ أن هناك مجموعتين كبيرتين من
الألواح الشمسية، أدناه  ثم في
المنتصف هناك سلسلة من المعدات،
أه الأقسام في الأساس عبارة عن
حزمة أدوات سيكون لها
كتلة لا بأس بها نظرًا لحجم
البالون، لذا إذا أطلقوا البالون لأسفل،
فمن المحتمل تمامًا أن
حزمة الأجهزة والشمس
في الواقع، يمكن أن تتسبب الألواح في حدوث ضرر أو من
المحتمل أن تلحق الضرر بالأشخاص الموجودين على
السطح بالأسفل عندما تتحطم،
حسنًا، ولكن يجب أن تسقط في بعض الأحيان،
لذا أين يمكن أن تهبط وبعد ذلك ماذا يحدث
بعد ذلك، هل ستفعل ذلك نوعًا ما، هل سنرى
جيمس بوند  مثل السباق
للوصول إليه أولاً،
حسنًا، كانت فكرتي الأولية هي أنني قمت بوضع
حمار وحشي إذا كنت تتذكر هذا الفيلم ولكن
في الأساس، نعم، يجب أن
ينزل في مرحلة ما، وبالتالي فإن
حزمة الأجهزة الموجودة على هذا البالون
ستكون ذات قيمة استخباراتية أه للولايات
المتحدة  من الواضح أن الولايات المتحدة تريد
السيطرة على أن الصينيين يريدون
منعهم من الحصول على ذلك، لذلك يعتمد الأمر حقًا
على مكان نزوله إذا
نزل فوق المحيط ربما في
خليج المكسيك أو على
المحيط الأطلسي أه أه  فإنه يمثل تحديًا من حيث
التعافي من الماء إذا
سقط على أرض يحتمل أن تكون فوق
أمريكا الوسطى أو المكسيك، وهذا
سيناريو أكثر تحديًا لأنه بعد ذلك
يقع في أراضي شخص آخر، لذا
سيكون من المثير للاهتمام أن نرى كيف تنتهي هذه
النهاية النهائية  اللعبة تعمل